some people believe that perhaps there's
a war on science that perhaps
politicians are meddling in the affairs
of science and doesn't that mean that
scientists should take a more of a moral
responsibility to speak out and I think
the answer is yes
in my field physics we have actually
been rather complacent for the last 50
years now remember the back in the 1920s
and 30s especially during the 40s
physicists were very definitely
politically active that's why we built
the atomic bomb we wanted to stop
fascism and nazism but during the Cold
War some people think we got fat because
every time we wanted something the
Pentagon would simply give it to us if
we needed a new particle accelerator we
would go to the United States Congress
and say one word just one word Russia
and then Congress would say two words
how much well those days are gone we all
know that the Russians aren't creating
new atom smashers anymore and therefore
we can't depend on Congress to fund our
budgets we have to in some sense sing
for our supper we have to in some sense
engage with the public and that's why I
think it's actually important for
scientists to make a statement to make a
statement about the great political
issues of the day because it impacts not
just on our science budget but actually
on our way of life now there been many
instances in the past where science have
has collided with politics when Einstein
for example was at the University of
Berlin he had qualms about the fact that
one of his next-door neighbors was Heinz
Harbor famous German chemist who worked
out the chemistry of that made possible
fertilizer but he also worked on poison
gas chlorine based poison gas and also
created poisons like a cyclone gas used
by the Nazis to gas Jews the irony is
that Heinz Harbor was a converted Jew
and his work was used to gas his own
relatives well that's why scientists
have to make an effort to engage the
public
the controversial issues for example
like evolution in biology evolution is
the organizing principle in the same way
that in physics relativity and the
quantum theory are the organizing
principles for all of physics and think
of the breakthroughs that we've made as
a consequence we can see the evolution
of viruses the evolution of germs that
has opened up a whole branch of medicine
by which we can then begin to conquer
viruses and diseases and when we go into
outer space and one day perhaps
encounter other life-forms perhaps they
too will obey the laws of evolution and
will be able to understand how life
throughout the universe also evolves so
on many levels at the level of medicine
healthcare at the level of basic
research is so important that science
not be corrupted in the process of
reaching public policy